counterpart like have an Asian character
in there they said no okay cool they
declined
[Music]
there's a new boss in town a DC Comics
we know we've known about this James
Gunn James Gunn took over yep and now he
has announced what he is going to be
doing with DC wait he's the CEO he's the
co-leader now like he's like Kevin feige
native director of that yeah the fight
you guy
okay is he gonna like construct though
you know how like yes the first Universe
was like it's around Iron Man so he's
gonna construct like the whole story and
like
so are they gonna do it around Robert
Pattinson then no so that's called DC
else worlds they're they're still gonna
let those movies go forward that's Matt
Reeves's project yeah because they're
doing the Joker one as well okay and the
Joker one and Matt Reeves has a series
about the penguin That's headed to to
HBO I'm like why do they never do the
penguin [__] are they gonna do it so
he's using Colin Farrell he's using
Colin Farrell oh that's cool because
he's a great I mean he's Colin Farrell's
a penguin not Danny DeVito he was in the
Batman oh with Robin pass I need to
watch it maybe wow you don't like Jared
Leto the [__] did you say Jared Leto's
my favorite Joker for real dude do you
want to study that out no he's my
favorite I think we should have brought
back Danny DeVito to be the penguin but
davido's Titus penguin it was the most
scariest penguin ever he was scariest
[__] it's funny that Daniel is mentioned
twice the last two days now dude Danny
DeVito's the man so it's hot right now
dude it's big on Jamie around here
so yeah two the first movie or the first
um chapter like remember MCU had phase
one this is gonna be called chapter one
Gods and Monsters oh cool and these are
the projects Batman Batman's coming yes
but the first one uh that he's focusing
on is Superman it's called Superman
Legacy and it's about his younger days
as a reporter at the Daily Planet and
like Smallville style huh in between
Smallville and in between I think it's
like after he lived in Smallville he's
living in Metropolis and then he's going
to be like struggling with his Human
Side versus his Kryptonian side oh
that's dope yeah that's kind of cool so
then that's so hard to find a struggle
for Superman yeah dude so lame yeah it's
tough it's tough is there a good flight
but I do like when they dive deep more
and then it's more human and there's
like a internal struggle kind of like
Joker that was sick Joker stiletto sugar
yeah yeah Jared Leto Joker was not so
what other what other movies are there
um so they're doing a a lifting Batman
movie
but it's gonna be about Batman's like
kid Damien Wayne instead of Dick Grayson
who does Damian Wayne become is he Damon
Wayans he becomes
later though later way later and then
they make really good you know black
blank man it's the prequel to The Wayans
bros yeah no he's gonna actually that's
kind of interesting that's kind of a
funny joke because
um Marlon Wayans was going to be Robin
in the 1919 really yeah 89. yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that would have been sick
but then they end up cutting that before
shooting and then they were they had him
signed on to do Batman Returns but then
they went a different direction decided
not to introduce Robin yet and so but he
was signed for two I think he was signed
for years wow he got paid out tonight
wow they paid him not to play Robin wow
interesting and they paid Billy D
Williams not to play Harvey Dent same
[__] no way yeah he was casting I love
Billy me too he was in the movie as
Harvey Dent but then he didn't get to be
two-faced
um yeah cause he was going to be in the
next ones and then didn't happen oh yeah
I haven't seen Two-Face in a minute yeah
two faces you haven't seen that
[__] wow yeah it's it's weird
because I feel a lot about two-faced I
feel like the entire like let's call it
the DC Universe uh or Cinematic Universe
if you will it's like gonna be really
really weird still for the next like two
years before we even really pick him up
they [__] up so bad on all because
like even like they still have The Flash
coming out out at the end of these here
they still have Aquaman 2 with Jason
Momoa so they haven't reset anything so
your public trust is death Matt Reeves
Batman with Robin Paxton that's like
these are else World projects so that
means that you've got this other like
everything's Frankenstein together but I
feel like if this dude is doing it James
Gunn is doing it it's probably gonna
have so much of a different look and
story than the rest of them that it's
gonna and probably well planned and
maybe maybe title differently too yeah
like even the suicide squad one like
that the second second Suicide Squad
versus the first one like is so
different so different second one's so
good yeah the tone there's so much
different like the first one that that's
gonna suck yeah Will Smith was sucks
[__] whack the second one is
like fun it's really good and then
because of that you get Peacemaker which
is probably like one of the only [__]
sick DC projects that everyone really
likes good one it was funny yeah like
it's a fun time so the Batman one you
you said he'll have a different title he
does it's called the Brave and the Bold
And it yeah introduces Damien Wayne who
is kind of an [__] Rob
yeah so he's like a little chip on his
shoulder a little [__] dude
um and then Robin's related to Batman no
the news there's a newer Robin oh his
name's James like several different oh
there's a bunch I see so then it'll be
more about the bat family and kind of a
father-son story kind of take and then
they're doing one uh called lanterns
which you might like Bart it's about all
green like the Chinese lanterns and
stuff but it's more of a True Detective
style series what yeah so it's like two
lantern two of the Green Lanterns
working together like John Hal Jordan
and Jon Stewart and they're like
investigating some [__] Jon Stewart with
Ryan Reynolds yeah Jon Stewart's one of
the the characters
oh I was like what the heck I was like
John Stewart's gonna be the guy cool
like a Shane Chi counterpart like have
an Asian character yeah they said no
Asians
DC no no no right always is the name or
I believe they all they're always
there's there's got to be like a very
like like a B-side character and he
probably does Kung Fu because I thought
something better in Marvel that everyone
knew was Green Lantern the Bruce Lee one
that's Green Hornet green horn Hornet oh
yeah yeah Green Lantern the white guy
yeah I like Agent Zero they mentioned
him just a little bit you remember that
one that's Marvel and Wolverine yeah
agent Zero's the guy who is the fastest
shirt that was dope there's a lot of
Marvel Asian characters they're just not
like Silver Samurai they made him a
[__] or like um Sunfire
oh yeah sunfires die or like the the
Korean Hulk
you ever heard of Korean Hulk that's his
name in the comic Sunfire I know how to
watch a crazy Hulk but he couldn't just
call him Cahill because Koreans get
angry oh that's true Bahan dude Hulk Kim
watch some Korean gamma rays they're
doing another movie called The or
another yeah movie called The Authority
based on a team of superheroes with
rather extreme methods of protecting the
planet that first originated from the
late 1990s under an influential imprint
known as Wild Storm comics wait who's
Wild Storm wow who's that who are the
superheroes that are in that group I
don't know I've never heard of them yeah
well storm isn't that with the is that
with grifter and like uh
is that well so they got deep cuts which
is cool they know who They're bringing
back for the DC Universe Swamp Thing
Swamp Thing is DC I [__] love you
like Swamp Thing yeah the movie was sick
dude yeah you don't remember watching
that [__] I love Swamp Thing I remember
the cartoon more than the movie is he a
good guy or a bad guy he's a good guy
he's a good guy the movie was very slow
oh wait I was a child I think of Toxic
Avenger
James Gunn is still writing Superman
Legacy he just started writing it yeah
wow who's who the Wild Storm franchise
characters is it oh that's not gen 13 is
it it's it's called Earth 50 I think
that's what they're calling it dude I
don't know anything about this which is
kind of cool though I think it was Jim
Lee's yeah it was Jim Lee's yeah it's
just it's gonna be weird because
everything's gonna feel so like one-off
like and non-continuous for the next two
years but even Marvel felt like that in
the beginning we're like wait are these
characters gonna make it to here and
then it wasn't until but with DC it's
like they're finishing old stories like
like Jason Momo's Aquaman was already a
part of like four different like DC
films you know what I'm saying and like
the flash is finally coming out and he
was part of the Justice League that was
Zack Snyder it was like Sarah and Keaton
Batman's coming back from in the flash
that's why they're always number two to
Marvel and James Gunn actually said the
flash was one of his favorite movies did
you say that yeah the flash was cool I
can't wait to watch that flash movie
because I am excited the character how
they do the flash he's the coolest
Justice League hero out of all like he's
the most interesting to me out of all
the Justice League you think the flashes
are cool really well just took my
Superman's Batman's Wonder women's as
far as from the movie I was like oh the
flat like his scenes are the coolest to
me oh just like the very quick
electrification slow motion running
stuff oh yeah Wonder Woman was DC I
forgot
yeah that was actually good the first
one was sick I think they just got to
make good Standalone movies right there
I think are they doing Supergirl as well
yeah they are doing Supergirl yep it's
supposed to be more mature and like a
darker twist or something it's based on
um this guy named Tom King a mini series
that he did about yeah she is she was
sent to Earth
um raised by loving parents
um or he Superman sent to Earth raised
by loving parents and Supergirl was
raised on a rock a chip off of Krypton
and watched everyone around her die and
be killed in terrible ways for the first
14 years dude she lived on a rock yeah
and then she comes to Earth so she's
like a little more hardcore yeah and
Kryptonian and Superman's kind of a
[__] compared to her yeah yeah she's
gonna beat his [__] ass dude so she
lived as a refugee that sounds gay but
it is but she's not as strong as
Superman and she can't compete like him
in sports
she can't throw it did she dunk even
though she could fly she can dunk yeah
okay they should make her Vietnamese
thank you
foreign